Hi folks, it's me, Dr. Johnson,
the edge. There is no honest way to explain it.
Cause the only people who really know where it is are the ones who have gone
over.
These are perfect words to describe the life of hunter S Thompson.
He was a writer who is best known for his semi autobiographical novel fear and
loathing in Las Vegas. And he was also the founder of Gonzo journalism.
He has gone down in history as being one of the wildest writers in American
history.
Hunters Thompson was born in Louisville, Kentucky on July, the 18th, 1937.
His father Jack was world war I veteran and an insurance salesman.
He was suffering from a disease called myasthenia gravis and passed away.
When hunter was just 14 years old, his mother,
Virginia was a librarian and she was left to shoulder.
All of the responsibilities alone.
She struggled financially and began drinking heavily to cope with her grief.
Hunter was very intelligent and it's really no surprise that being raised by a
librarian helped him in his love of books. When he entered high school,
he joins a club called the Athena literary association.
They wrote and newsletter together,
and Thompson was always very witty and sarcastic through this literary society.
He became friends with the rich kids in town,
since they were the only ones who shared his passion for reading and writing.
Most of the boys in Kentucky enjoyed practicing marksmanship and hunting wild
animals in the woods hunter he did as well,
but he was sort of caught in between both of the worlds since his family was so
poor.
He felt like an outsider to his new friend group.
His friends began to vandalized and participated in robberies and neighborhoods,
and they were even able to get alcohol. Despite being underage one night,
they were caught by the police and kept in custody.
His friends all had rich parents who were able to pay lawyers and get them bail.
Unfortunately Fahan his mother could not afford to pay for his legal defense.
Ended up serving time in jail and could not attend his own high school
graduation. In 1956, he decided to join the us air for,
but he wasn't exactly good at taking orders.
He began writing for the air force base newspaper,
but his defamatory claims got him in so much trouble that he was discharged in
1957,
All writers, Evan author,
that they look up to and hunter S Thompson's favorite authors were F Scott
Fitzgeral and Ernest Hemingway. He would read the great Gatsby and to farewell,
to arms and wish that he could write with that same kind of emotion.
He decided that he would copy the book word for word on his typewriter over and
over again,
just to feel the rhythm of what it was like to write his favorite books.
He spent a year living in Rio de Janee writing for the English language
newspaper called the Herald. This gig only lasted a year though.
And he returned to the United States to marry his longtime girlfriend,
Sonny Wright in 1963, they moved to Aspen Colorado together.
Instead of working on a staff,
he became a freelance journalist making roughly a hundred dollars per article.
He would hunt out. So he and his wife had something to eat,
but they barely ate any food. Aside from that,
there were many months when they almost didn't make their rent.
They had a son together named Juan Fitzgerald Thompson.
Sadly son suffered through five more miscarriages and Juan remained their only
child in 19 6400 S Thompson reported on the suicide of Hemingway and Idaho.
He stole Sam antlers and a that had been hanging on the wall from the famous
writer as a souvenir hunter and his family.
They then moved to California and he encountered hippie culture in San
Francisco. For the first time,
he was given an assignment by a publication called the nation,
requesting that he do an investigative piece on the motorcycle gang called the
hell's angels.
They were known for being incredibly dangerous and purposely trying to break all
of the rules of, of society.
Many journalists had attempted to write about the gang before,
but they were too afraid to get involved.
But hunter, he was wild enough to hang and he fit in just fine.
During one of the parties,
Thompson witnessed one of the gang members beating his wife and his dog hunter
then approached the man saying only a punk beats, his wife and dog,
the gang beat up Thompson for defending the man's wife.
His was a pulp and his ribs were broken.
He went to the police station and reported the beatings to the authorities.
Cause to that point that he realized he didn't really wanna be involved with the
hell's angels.
Any longer Thompson wrote, I was finished, the angels had taken me to the edge.
There could be no going back now, even if I wanted to hunters,
compiled his articles into a book called hell's angels, a strange and terrible.
He was given a $15,000 check as in advance.
And he used the money to buy a house and some land in Aspen, Colorado,
which he named Al fun.
And he lived there for the rest of his life. When the book was published,
it was on the New York times best seller list.
Despite the success hunter wanted to continue to push himself to do better with
his writing career.
After the time he spent with hell's angels hunter S Thompson for and obsession
with collecting guns, he used them to hunt,
but he was also interested in marksmanship and practice shooting targets on a
daily basis is also probably not a incidence that he started collecting guns
after becoming hated by one of the most violent gangs in the country.
Even after the success of his first book,
hum S Thompson was still a freelance journalist.
His success helped him secure work for various magazines where he offered to
cover sporting events while working for Scanlons monthly.
He became friends with an illustrator named Ralph Steadman and he introduced him
to drugs.
For the first time Tedman took a sinus Ibin mushrooms before they went to go
watch the 1970 Kentucky dirty during the race Tedman illustrated the people in
the crowds who were watching gambling and drinking their drugs greatly
heightened the atmosphere of the race for them.
The article he ultimately wrote about the event was titled the Kentucky Derby is
decadent and depraved. After that piece was published,
one of Thompson's coworkers commented that piece was totally Gonzo as in,
it was totally nuts.
First Thompson felt as if the piece had been one of his biggest failures and he
decided that he would never do drugs before writing again to his surprise
though, he began to get phone calls from people who called him brilliant.
He realized that the style of writing was actually working in his favor and he
decided to call it Gonzo journalism. He later said, I hate to advocate drugs,
alcohol violence, or insanity to anyone, but they've always worked for me.
He continued this Gonzo style in fear and lathing in Las Vegas.
What should have been a relatively boring day in the desert reporting on a
motorcycle race became a psychedelic adventure about searching for the American
dream rolling stone. And he really wanted a few paragraphs describing the race.
But hunter had come back with a 60 page manifesto about everything had
experienced while high on drugs.
The story was published and he got a book deal with random house publishing
after the success of fear and living in Las Vegas,
hunter S Thompson sought this as evidence that he needed to continue his
wildlife lifestyle.
He began to take drugs and drink pretty much every day of his hunter re Thompson
once rode out his daily routine, where he consumed so many substances.
It is truly a miracle that he didn't die of. A heart attack. 3:00 PM rise,
3 0 5 shivers Regel with the morning papers,
Dunhill 3 45 cocaine 4 0 5 first cup of coffee downhill.
Then between four and 5:00 PM, he snorts more cocaine at 6:00 PM.
He smokes grass to take the edge off the day.
Then finally he leaves at 7:05 PM to the Woody Creek Tavern for lunch
Heineken, two margaritas coleslaw, or taco salad,
a double order of fried onion rings, carrot cake, ice cream,
a bean fretter Dunhill, another Heineken cocaine. And for the ride home,
a snow cone, a glass of shreded eyes over,
which is poured three or four jiggers of shva 9:00 AM starts snorting cocaine.
Seriously. This goes on until midnight.
When he finally starts writing until 8:00 AM. When he falls asleep,
Many people know about hunter S Thompson's reputation for getting high and
shooting guns,
but far fewer people know about out his attempt at establishing a political
career. In 1968,
he witnessed the rats at the democratic national convention and wrote that the
brutality shown by the police beating protestors was 10 times worse than
anything it ever witnessed while living with the hell's angels.
He wrote that the American dream was clubbing itself to death.
Tom believed that the city of Aspen was being destroyed because trees were being
on down to make way for new roads and luxury homes.
For people who are coming to have a skiing holiday,
he wanted to push for preserving the natural landscape and making marijuana
legal in Colorado.
This attention to its campaign brought a lot of hippies to visit Aspen. In 1970,
he wrote about the mayor election of 19 6 69 for rolling stone magazine.
And he titled the article of about full of Aspen.
He got such a huge response from readers that he decided that he would run for
sheriff of picking county Colorado in 1970. At first,
his campaign sort of started as a joke because he knew that he had absolutely no
experience in politics, but the longer he went on,
the more we started to believe that he could actually win.
He convinced a lot of people to register to vote.
He would never participate in a local election before his campaign team began to
hang posters around town.
With his logo of raised fist with two thumbs holding a peyote cactus.
This became known as the Gonzo fist hunter was balding.
So he asked the barber to completely shave his head just so he could deliver a
joke in his speech. Unlike my longhaired opponents,
he got into the habit of wearing long ridiculous wigs.
One of the editors of rolling stone said during an interview,
the TMS arrest Thompson was switching out his wigs multiple times.
During one conversation,
his friends helped tons film a commercial for his campaign,
which was basically just him riding a motorcycle, but his fans,
they loved it all. The same.
Only thing against him is he's a visionary. He wants to.
Pure a world, not surprisingly.
He lost the election and he never got to serve as sheriff,
but it did inspire him to continue writing about politics in fear and lathing on
the campaign trail, 72,
he began to get a bit of a reputation for being an anus rather than a real
journalist. Since he was not trying to become a political reporter,
full time hunters, Thompson, he was not afraid to insult the politicians.
And anyone else that he noticed was acting ridiculously on the campaign trail.
He also didn't need to worry about burning political bridges because he wasn't
gonna be there long anyway, because of his brutal honesty,
his journalism caught the attention of the politicians more than the typical
articles that were being written about them.
He absolutely hated Richard Nixon with a fiery passion.
He compare at him and his family to Barbie dolls.
He said that Nixon represented everything that was wrong with the United States.
Even when he died.
Thompson wrote a scathing eulogy in rolling stone where the subject line said
the death of Richard Nixon notes on the passing of an American monster.
He was a liar and a quitter, and he should have been buried at sea,
but he was after all the president in his books on politics,
he sought to see if it was even possible for a good man to become a politician.
He concluded that George McGovern was the closest thing to a good man on the
campaign trail. Versus of course he didn't win the presidential election.
Just like all of the subjects that he wrote about.
He felt that this was just another one where the American dream was dead during
the next election hunters,
Thompsons and wrote about Jimmy Carter on the campaign trail.
And many people believe that his articles actually helped him become president.
At that point,
people trusted his insights into the character of these politicians.
Thompson became one of the most memorable political writers of his time.
And he broke every single rule along the way.
In 1980, bill Murray started in a comedy movie called where the Buffalo Rome,
which was based on his various exploits journalist because they used his real
name in the movie. This launched Thompson to a new level of fame.
He also inspired a carer called uncle duke in the dunes comic strip Thompson
became friends with other celebrities like Jimmy buffet, Bob Dylan,
Jack Nicholson, and bill Murray. He struggled with the fact to that.
Everyone imagined him as this caricature of the person that they saw in fear in
loathing, in Las Vegas and the comic strip.
They made him feel like people had this expectation that he should behave Gonzo
24 7. Because of that,
he began to sharp up to interviews completely high or acting crazy because he
thought that that's what people expected of him during an interview with the
BBC.
He said that the myth of his car chair had become bigger than who he truly was.
He stated most people are surprised that I walk on two legs.
The idea that I would have a wife or a child,
I think people think I'm a violent version of that comic strip.
He also stated about the myth.
This myth is growing and mushrooming and getting more and more warped.
When I get invited to speak to universities,
I don't know who they're inviting duke or Thompson. I'm not sure who to be.
It makes me want to kill off one life and start another one.
He reached a point where even if people had not read his articles or books,
they knew him from the movies and the comic groupies began to flirt with him and
flock to the wood.
He Creek Tavern because it was well known that he loved to hang out there.
Even after he became famous. When he was awake,
he would invite strangers over to the house. Enough parties.
Hunter was caught having multiple affairs with these women.
Eventually his wife had had an after she asked for a divorce in 1980,
at this point,
he was such a successful and famous writer that the editor at rolling stone did
not know what kind of assignments to give him any more.
It would almost seem as though nothing was worthy of hunters, Thompson,
he was assigned to cover a boxing match with Mohammed Ali because he had written
about him successfully in the past,
in his typical Gonzo style Thompson got high and swam in the hotel pool.
Hunter missed Mohammed.
Ali's fight completely when asked what he thought of the match.
Thompson replied, what fight? Oh, I didn't go to the fight.
I stayed in the hotel, swimming pool, lay on my back, looking at the moon,
coming up.
And the only person in the hotel came and stared me a long time before he went
away. Maybe he thought I was a corpse. I floated there naked.
I'd thrown a pounds and a half of marijuana into the pool.
It was what I had left and I'm not trying to smuggle it outta this country.
And it stuck together there in a sort of clot.
And then it began to spread out in a green slick. It was very luxurious,
floating naked in that stuff though.
It's not the best way to obtain a high needless to say,
paying him to get high ends, not write a story.
Isn't exactly good for business stunts.
Like this proved that he was no longer as prolific as he once was.
He was forced to take a break from writing.
Thompson had earned a significant amount of money from his book sales and
selling movie rides.
So he was able to essentially retire from his journalism career when they began
filming fear in loathing in Las Vegas in 1997,
Johnny Depp wanted to get to know him so that he could portray the character
more accurately.
On the day they met DPP said that he was asked to meet hunters Thompson at the
Woody Creek Tavern.
Hunter may at a grand entrance by holding a cattle pro that was lighting up the
room with sparks.
People were jumping outta the way as Thompson shouted outta my way.
Your bastards, obviously this made quite the impression of Johnny depen.
He started living with hunters Thompson in order to understand him better.
They spent many long nights shooting guns,
blowing things up and reading books to one another. During this time,
hunter ask Johnny Depp to read out his own work to him.
Thompson explained him the exact cadence of how he wanted his work to be read.
Deb stumbled upon the unpublished manuscript of a book called the rum diary,
which told the story of one of his adventures in Puerto Rico.
When he was in his early twenties,
he read it since encouraged Thompson to publish it. So he finally did.
Johnny Depp would also go on star in a movie version of the rum diary. In 2011,
for years,
Thompson had told his friends and family that he planned to kill himself.
One day when he met his second wife, Anita,
when she began working as his personal assistant in 1999,
they fell in love and got married. That happened in 2003 on February, the 20th,
2005, Anita had just made him breakfast.
And she noticed that hunter was acting strange.
He told her to get out of the room. This shocked her because he had never,
before been so cruel to her.
She left the house and he called her to apologize and say that she should come
back. If she wanted to. However,
she began to hear clicking noises on the other end,
Anita assumed he was about to use the typewriter. But when she ID home,
she realized that he had committed suicide.
And those clicking noises were the sounds of him preparing a gun. His son,
Juan was the one to find the body because he had been at home at the time,
even long before his suicide,
he was already making plans for a monument to be built for his funeral. And,
and even at a film crew document him preparing his last willin Testament.
He asked to have his ashes shot out of a fist shaped cannon loads of his
celebrity friends straight off to his funeral.
And it looked more like an extravagant party.
There was a stage full of Japanese drummers and colorful fireworks went off
before the ashes were scattered over the mountains of Colorado after his death,
his wife, Anita didn't want to touch anything in his office,
which he called the war room. Years later, after she had time to grieve,
it became clear that Tundras Thompson had become a legendary writer.
She decided to turn it into a museum and allow his fans to see it.
She also runs an organization called the Gonzo foundation where she plans to
open up Al farm for writing retreats.
Even though there are plenty of his friends and family who still miss dearly
Thompson wouldn't have wanted anyone to feel sad about his death. He once said,
life should not be a journey to the grave with the intention of arriving safely
in a press and well preserved body,
but rather to ski in broadside in a cloud of smoke thoroughly used up totally
worn out and loudly proclaiming. Wow, what a ride.
So I really hope you found that video. Interesting. If you did,
please do gives a thumbs up below. We got brand new videos several times a week.
So be sure to subscribe to this channel. Also,
if you're looking at something else from me,
why not check on my other and awkward today?
I found out you'll find that linked to below as always. Thank you for watching.